digamos que tenemos una masa que está
conectada a un resorte y este a su vez
está conectado al techo si le damos un
impulso a esta masa va a comenzar a
oscilar de arriba a abajo una y otra y
otra vez y si yo quisiera dibujar este
movimiento pues mi dibujo estaría sobre
escribiéndose en el mismo lugar y no se
vería nada bien así que nos olvidamos de
esto y digamos que dibujamos la posición
de la masa cada cuarto de segundo
comenzamos aquí pasa un cuarto de
segundo y ahora está aquí todo esto es
una masa simplemente tomamos imágenes de
ella y estamos separando estas imágenes
poniéndolas una junto a otra si
conectamos las imágenes de la masa vamos
a tener una gráfica que básicamente es
la altura de esta masa como función del
tiempo y luce así si yo fuera a graficar
esto en una gráfica de posición vertical
contra tiempo tendríamos algo así
comenzamos en el medio luego subimos
luego bajamos
hasta llegar a la posición más baja
luego vuelve a subir y este proceso se
repite y ustedes pueden ver que esto
luce como una gráfica de seno pero esta
es mi pregunta digamos que la masa no
comenzó en el medio y la empujamos hacia
arriba digamos que ahora comenzamos con
la masa hasta arriba y la dejamos caer
en otras palabras hacemos esto tenemos
la masa aquí arriba en la dejamos caer y
la gráfica se verá así ahora si fuéramos
a graficar esto aquí tendremos una
gráfica que luce así comenzamos hasta
arriba va bajando pasa por el punto
medio y llega hasta el punto más bajo
luego vuelve a subir y se repite el
proceso una y otra y otra vez ahora mi
pregunta es estas gráficas son iguales o
son diferentes
bueno obviamente son diferentes pero
casi todo es lo mismo su amplitud es la
misma es decir tienen el mismo
desplazamiento a partir de la posición
de equilibrio la amplitud es la misma su
periodo es el mismo
todo es el tiempo entre oscilaciones así
que ambos periodos son iguales lo único
que es diferente es que una de las
gráficas está desplazada en comparación
con la otra
de hecho vean esto si yo tomo esta
gráfica verde la inicial y la desplazó
hacia la izquierda vamos a tener
exactamente la misma gráfica son casi
iguales solamente que una está
desplazada hacia la izquierda y la
palabra que usan los físicos para
describir cuando una gráfica es igual a
otra pero está desplazada es el término
de fase podemos decir que estos
osciladores están fuera de fase que tan
diferentes en fases están bueno un ciclo
completo y día de aquí hasta acá y no
están desfasadas todo un ciclo sólo
están desplazadas esta cantidad y esto
es para este caso que dibuje es
solamente un cuarto de ciclo así que
podemos decir que están desfasadas un
cuarto de ciclo o si pensamos en el
círculo unitario
sabemos que un cuarto del ciclo
corresponde a 90 grados api entre dos si
hablamos en radiales y esto es lo que
tienen estas gráficas están desfasadas
90 grados api entre dos radiales así que
como describimos esta idea de fase así
que como describimos esta idea de fase
matemáticamente si quisiéramos escribir
una ecuación para este oscilador verde
digamos que está igual a cero empieza
aquí voy a escribir que es una función
del tiempo es decir la altura de este
oscilador es una función del tiempo y
esta será la amplitud multiplicada por y
ya que ésta comienza en cero voy a usar
seno porque sé que el seno comienza en
cero cuando t es igual a cero el seno de
dos pi entre el periodo muy delicado por
el tiempo está t minúscula representa el
tiempo y es nuestra variable
independiente vamos a asegurarnos de que
esta ecuación funciona
y aquí ponemos de igual a cero el seno
de 0 es igual a 0
así que todo esto es 0 y es lo que debo
tener aquí millet debe ser igual a 0
cuando me dé es 0 vamos bien y conforme
t minúscula se va haciendo más grande
esta parte de adentro se vuelve un poco
más grande cada vez y el seno de una
cantidad pequeña positiva va a ser un
número pequeño positivo y es por eso que
esta gráfica aumenta a partir de aquí
eventualmente llega al pico y dónde va a
alcanzar este pico va a llegar a este
pico cuando haya pasado un cuarto del
ciclo recuerden que un ciclo es toda
esta cantidad de aquí es toda esta parte
de aquí así que un cuarto de ciclo es
cuando llegamos a la amplitud desde cero
y esto se da en el tiempo igual a el
periodo entre cuatro
ya que esto es una cuarta parte del
ciclo y la matemática nos da esto sí sí
lo hace si yo reemplazo mi te minúscula
que es mi variable de tiempo con esto t
entre cuatro me queda que el seno de dos
pi entre t por t entre cuatro
las tres o los periodos se cancelan y me
queda el seno de dos pi entre cuatro es
igual a pie entre dos y pi entre dos es
90 grados el seno de 90 grados o el seno
de pie entre dos radiales es igual a uno
y es lo más grande que puede llegar a
estar el seno y uno por la amplitud es
la amplitud así que obtendré el valor de
la altura de la amplitud y esto va a
describir a mi oscilador perfectamente
ya que nos va a dar la altura en
cualquier instante de tiempo esto no
estuvo mal pero qué tenemos que hacer
para describir al oscilador púrpura y
ustedes me pueden decir vaya esto es muy
fácil vamos a hacer este seno un coseno
y bueno si para este caso si funciona
pero imagínense que no saben cómo hacer
esto o si lo quieren hacer más difícil
digamos que esto no es igual a una
cuarta parte del ciclo digamos que está
desfasado una novena parte del ciclo en
este caso el coseno no nos va a servir
necesitamos una forma más general para
ajustar el desplazamiento que hay aquí y
eso va a ser una constante de fase aquí
donde vamos a poner la constante pues
pueden decir que tomamos la gráfica
verde y la vamos a desplazar a la
izquierda pueden decir bueno puedo
restar algo una cantidad aquí eso no va
a funcionar ya que esto me va a restar a
mi gráfica del valor total que yo
obtenga aquí una cantidad constante en
cada ocasión por lo que esto va a hacer
que mi gráfica se desplace hacia abajo
y esto no nos va a funcionar si
sumáramos un valor de b aquí tampoco nos
va a funcionar porque lo único que va a
hacer es desplazar nuestra gráfica hacia
arriba así que este valor de b no nos va
a servir nos podría servir para algunas
situaciones pero no en esta en donde
queremos desplazar la gráfica a la
derecha oa la izquierda lo que vamos a
necesitar es agregar una constante a
dentro del argumento donde el seno si yo
quiero describir mi oscilador púrpura
diría que ya es función del tiempo y
esto es igual a la amplitud la misma que
la anterior nuevamente vamos a usar seno
y vamos a tener que es de 2 pi entre el
periodo multiplicado por el tiempo y es
aquí donde vamos a agregar la constante
de fase aquí
sumamos esta constante de fase quizá
ustedes piensen que debemos restar ya
que queremos desplazarlo hacia la
izquierda pero resulta que sumar una
constante de fa se va a desplazar la
gráfica a la izquierda esto no es muy
intuitivo que digamos
a mí siempre me confunde cómo es que
agregar una constante de fase me
desplaza la gráfica a la izquierda pero
vean si tomamos esta ecuación y en lugar
de poner fin aquí y ese es el símbolo
que usamos para la constante de fase en
general y en este caso ya sabemos que el
valor debe tener debe ser un cuarto del
ciclo y para una gráfica de seno el
cuarto de ciclo es pi entre 2
veamos si esto funciona cuando t es
igual a cero solíamos tener cero porque
eso nos servía para la ecuación verde
pero para el oscilador púrpura necesito
comenzar en el valor máximo y para t
igual a cero todo eso de aquí se vuelve
cero y nos queda el seno de pie entre
dos y el seno de pie entre 2 es 1
justamente por eso elegimos este valor
para poder tener el máximo valor del
seno y multiplicarlo por la amplitud así
obtendremos la amplitud que es lo que
queremos en esta gráfica queremos que
comience con la amplitud y esto
es mejor que poner solamente coseno al
menos mejor de lo que sabíamos antes
porque ahora este desplazamiento porque
ahora este desplazamiento de fase podría
ser pie entre 9 upi / 27 podemos
desplazarla por la cantidad que
querramos usando seno o cosano ahora
sabemos cómo desplazar a desfasar esta
función si agregamos una constante de
fase el desplazamiento va a ser hacia la
izquierda el restar la constante de fase
nos va a desplazar la función a la
derecha y mientras más grande sea la
constante de fase mayor será el
desplazamiento y no es necesario
desplazarla más de 2 p ya que en dos
vamos a obtener el mismo desplazamiento
es decir va a coincidir de nuevo esta
constante aquí que en este caso es pie
entre dos en general luce así tenemos un
oscilador que tiene cierta amplitud
podemos usar seno o coseno más una
constante de fase iii esta constante de
fase va a determinar cuánto se desplaza
pasa este oscilador a la derecha oa la
izquierda y les comento que hay que
tener cuidado porque aquí los físicos
pueden ser descuidados y usar la misma
palabra para varias cosas a veces la
palabra fase se usa para esta parte de
aquí para agregar la parte constante
pero a veces por fase la gente se
refiere a todo esto de aquí todo lo que
está como el argumento de la función
seno coseno ya que esto es lo que
determina en donde nos encontramos en
todo nuestro ciclo y esas ideas no sólo
aplican para una masa en un resorte
podemos escribir la ecuación de una onda
y aquí tendríamos un término extra para
el espacio y no solo el tiempo y
adivinen tendríamos una constante aquí
que podríamos agregar o restar y que
sería la constante de fase así que esta
idea de fase nos da una manera de
describir como dos osciladores o dos
ondas están desfasadas o desplazadas
mutuamente entre sí
nos permite encontrar varias propiedades
como la que tenemos aquí para esta masa
en el resorte